[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa noite
é tá chegando à noite é atingir rosa do
sul de belo horizonte
eu venho conversando com o taxista no
caminho ele pergunta o que você foi
fazendo esforços
eu falei assim a vir aqui mas é uma
alerta sobre o tema não volto bastante
tudo o que é a falecer ao falar sobre
educação político falar sobre a
democracia
agora você é caro brasil está muito
difícil né gata problema a situação está
muito grave as pessoas aderem os mesmos
políticos
aquela mesma percepção que a gente
tradicionalmente tem né
as pessoas têm sobre a política em geral
no brasil que a política chato que
política partidarizado política é muito
difícil é uma molecada tudo tem solução
essa foi um sol que equipa a apresentar
para vocês nos falamos nesse caso
especificamente sobre esse estádio estão
grande político que admiro bastante
distante ótimo diante disse uma frase eu
gosto bastante ele diz o seguinte a
democracia é a melhor forma de governo
com exceção de todas as outras que já
foram testados mas quando a gente
continua a não saudáveis democracia
brasileira
a gente teve essa frase de um time muito
relevante vai ver que muitos de vocês
conhecem esse momento esse momento da
promulgação da nossa constituição em
mas a pergunta era fazer para vocês é a
seguinte será que nós de fato temos uma
constituição a qual podemos chamar de
nossa eu trouxe alguns pontos para falar
sobre a nossa constituição o primeiro
ponto sobre a nossa constituição o
seguinte a constituição brasileira em 23
anos e 88 2011 aprovou 67 emendas
comparativamente à constituição dos
estados unidos em 224 anos de existência
aprovou 27 emendas então a pergunta que
eu faço pra vocês é a seguinte será que
quantidade é sinônimo de qualidade
outro ponto importante quando a
constituição foi aprovada em 1988
muitas pessoas entenderam que a
constituição estava ali pra agradar
diferentes grupos políticos porque
existe um artigo da nossa constituição
fala o seguinte existe a defesa da
propriedade privada desde que a
verdade privada atenda uma função social
bom mas a esse discurso é um pouco
difícil de entender se é propriedade
privada função social isso é um pouco
amigo
outro ponto relevante do artigo 7 do
direito do trabalhador urbano e rural
dentre várias emendas que tivemos nesse
artigo 7 uma dizia que o trabalhador
estaria protegido em face à automação da
produção na forma da lei ou seja avanços
tecnológicos avanços produto
todos eles estariam proibidos em função
da proteção ao trabalhador mas tem um
ponto muito importante da nossa
constituição especialmente após o
período militar que foi a garantia das
liberdades individuais mas uma outra
análise que eu trago para vocês é o
seguinte na nossa constituição a palavra
garantia aparece 46 vezes
já a palavra direitos aparece 16 vezes
enquanto a palavra deve desaparece
apenas quatro vezes
então será que nós temos de fato uma
constituição que nos garante tanto
naquilo que a gente deve fazer com
aquilo que o governo a sociedade também
deve entregar pra nós
essa é a pergunta que eu ea nazaré
tedesco queremos fazer para vocês
será que de fato a nossa constituição
ela é tão democrática quanto a gente
imagina
e vejam que interessante essa pesquisa
adequando-a me fez uma publicação em
2016 para entender qual era pra entender
qual era o nível de democracia no brasil
e chegaram à seguinte resultado o brasil
está na 51ª colocação em relação ao
nível de democracia comparado com outros
países do mundo porque por causa de dois
fatores especiais participação política
e cultura política e sabe que é o pior
de tudo em cultura política que a nossa
nota e 3,75
nós somos a pior nota da américa latina
e nós estamos bem próximos daquela que é
considerada a pior democracia do mundo
que a coreia do norte
a nota da coreia do norte 1,25 a gente
não está muito distante deles não mas
vão entender então que são esses pontos
especificamente cultura política quer
dizer a afinidade que o brasileiro tem
com regimes autoritários afinidade que o
brasileiro tem com regimes militares
qual é a conexão que o brasileiro tem
condição
da política como o brasileiro enxerga a
democracia como um fator importante para
o desenvolvimento econômico brasileiro e
por fim como o brasileiro enxerga a
separação entre estado e igreja e nós
estamos péssimamente colocados nessa
análise um pouco à frente falando sobre
participação política aqui a gente tem
alguns critérios que nos garantiram
aquela péssima nota também por exemplo a
participação do brasileiro na política
em relação ao voto
a representatividade feminina no
congresso nacional pra vocês terem idéia
o brasil é a 116ª posição no ranking de
representatividade feminina no congresso
nacional muito ruim uma posição muito
ruim também
e por fim outro ponto importante é ponto
brasileiro se interessa por política e
só 40% dos brasileiros nessa pesquisa
indicaram que têm interesse por política
e vejam os da relevante 96% dos
brasileiros não se sentem representados
pelos políticos nós temos um dado ainda
mais interessante aqui no próximo slide
que diz o seguinte 97% dos brasileiros
acreditam que é necessário haver
renovação da política brasileira
o maravilha a gente sabe aonde a gente
tem que chegar a gente sabe que precisa
renovar vão trocar todo mundo trocar o
congresso troca câmera troca presidente
troca tudo mas acho que a gente sofre de
um mal súbito
depois das eleições que é o seguinte
amnésia após período eleitoral sabe que
isso significa exatamente isso aqui ó
79% dos eleitores não lembram em quem
votaram o congresso nacional em 2014 eu
acredito que muitos de vocês também não
se lembram em quem vocês votaram para o
congresso para deputado estadual e
federal em 2014 então é maravilha a
gente sabe onde a gente quer chegar
mas a gente não sabe como é que a gente
faz para chegar lá e nem o caminho que a
gente vai seguir
e sabe qual a conseqüência disso tudo
efeitos tanto na segurança na saúde em
corrupção são responsabilidades da
sociedade brasileira
vejam por aqui o fundo eleitoral das
últimas eleições agora de 2018 foi
estimado em 1,7 bilhão de reais de
recursos públicos destinados à campanha
de partidos
políticos nas últimas eleições nós
tivemos agora em 2018
outro ponto muito relevante sobre
educação olha esse dado que tristeza
trinta por cento dos estudantes que
concluem o ensino fundamental com nível
adequado de português e só 14% dos
estudantes concluem com nível adequado
de matemática e nós temos mais problemas
no brasil por exemplo segurança
no brasil nós temos uma taxa de 60 mil
homicídios por ano em são paulo
considerado o estado mais desenvolvido
do nosso país só 5% desses homicídios
foram julgados mais dados 13 milhões de
brasileiros vivem em situação de extrema
extrema pobreza ou seja eles têm menos
do que 1,9 dólares por dia
já 52 milhões de brasileiros ou seja
mais ou menos 25% da população vive
abaixo da linha da pobreza com menos de
5,5 dólares por dia
e aí falando sobre corrupção um tema que
está tão em voga né aqui especialmente
nas últimas eleições nos últimos anos
que a gente tem visto no brasil
estima-se que 100 bilhões de reais são
desviados para a corrupção
imaginem quantos hospitais quantas
escolas quanto de investimento não
poderia ser feito com 100 bilhões de
reais
é muito dinheiro muito dinheiro e qual é
a raiz do nosso problema da democracia
quem são os principais culpados do
problema da nossa democracia
sabe quem são nós brasileiros nós somos
os principais culpados não é o governo
não são os políticos somos nós porque a
gente sabe a gente quer chegar
mas a gente não faz nada para poder
chegar lá e é o trouxe uma frase que eu
gosto bastante que é
não sabemos o que não sabemos mas
esperamos muito daquilo que pouco
conhecemos que retratam acreditados que
o trouxe do renova e da exame onde a
gente quer renovar mas a gente nem
lembra em quem a gente votou nas últimas
eleições e esse índice de democracia
local foi de uma pesquisa promovida pelo
instituto atuação para entender tudo bem
o brasil tem um problema é geral de
democracia mas vamos entendendo micro
vamos lá na cidade entender qual é o
problema da democracia local
primeira pesquisa foi em curitiba e o
índice de democracia local em curitiba
ficou em 49% abaixo da metade muito ruim
também por dois motivos quais são eles
cultura política e participação política
e olha os dados interessantes só 27% dos
curitibanos afirmaram que teriam certeza
em quem votar
se o voto fosse obrigatório ou seja o
voto no brasil então virou uma mera
formalidade porque se você não tem
certeza que quem está votando citadino
lá só pra cumprir a sua obrigação como
cidadão de quatro em quatro anos ou de
dois em dois e se a gente comparar as
eleições nas esferas diferentes
em outro ponto relevante nessa pesquisa
com os curitibanos
mais de 90% dos curitibanos afirmaram
que nunca foram assistir a uma sessão de
votação numa assembleia numa câmera em
nada e 77% dos curitibanos afirmaram que
eles nunca participaram de uma
manifestação política então gente se a
gente não fizer a nossa parte e ficar
esperando o governo fazer alguma coisa
para a democracia do brasil melhorar
para o nosso dia-a-dia melhorar
nós não vamos sair do lugar não e aí foi
o que aconteceu com o nosso trabalho um
pouco mais à frente que foi o politize
quem a associação é o trabalho que eu já
estou representando aqui o politize é o
maior portal de educação política do
brasil hoje o político começou em 2015
após as manifestações 2013 porque nós
entendemos que as pessoas estavam na rua
mas elas não sabiam porque elas estavam
na rua o que elas estavam fazendo ali
elas não sabem nem o que é que faz um
deputado federal e estava lá cobrando de
deputado federal então político começou
como um portal voltado para a educação
política das pessoas e esse foi o nosso
objetivo foi a causa que a gente abraçou
pra melhorar aqueles dois critérios
iniciais que eu apresentei para vocês
naqueles light lá da pesquisa da the
economist e o nosso objetivo diário é
educação para o exercício diário da
cidadania e da democracia e esses são os
nossos dois pilares a gente só vai
conseguir melhorar isso com educação e
com a educação política para que a gente
possa atuar de maneira local e assim
melhorar a democracia do brasil como um
todo e um objetivo nosso também é cuba
mas fique news porque todo o nosso
conteúdo não tem nenhum viés ideológico
ou partidário
quem acessar o nosso portal lado
politize vai entender e vai encontrar
tudo de educação política sem viés
ideológico e partidário vocês terem
idéia da dimensão de fake news no mundo
hoje
nas últimas eleições presidenciais nos
estados unidos as fake news tiveram mais
relevância do que as notícias divulgadas
pelos 19 principais veículos de
comunicação dos estados unidos então
entendam a dimensão ainda nem
conseguiram mensurar qual foi o impacto
das flec news nas últimas eleições
presidenciais que nós tivemos agora no
brasil e aí alguns números dos nossos
impactos aqui hoje lá no político no
nosso portal nós já temos 15 milhões de
usuários únicos 3.5 milhões de contos
views por mês 145 milhões de minutos de
aprendizado e quinhentos e cinquenta por
cento de crescimento em dois anos
e falando sobre o nosso impacto offline
que a nossa rede embaixadores a qual eu
sou embaixador
hoje a gente já conseguiu atingir 84
municípios somos 157 embaixadores e já
realizamos 400 e 480 atividades
realizadas com impacto total de
aproximadamente 20 mil pessoas
diretamente
então esse é o nosso trabalho essa é a
nossa contribuição essa tem sido a nossa
micro revolução para a gente poder
melhorar a democracia brasileira
e aí é que eu trouxe algumas fotos para
compartilhar com vocês
nesses momentos que eu tive como
embaixador eu fui embaixador que mais
impactou pessoas conseguem impactar
1.100 pessoas ao longo de uns quatro
meses mais ou menos e um trabalho
voluntário mas que eu acredito porque
quando finalizei brevemente falando
sobre a minha história quando finalizei
a graduação na espanha eu tive
oportunidade de largar o brasil e ficar
na espanha para construir o futuro lago
foi aprovado no mestrado
resolvi voltar porque eu sei que a minha
causa tac e se eu não fizer minha parte
nós jovens não fizemos a nossa parte
qual vai ser o futuro do brasil então
trouxe algumas fotos aqui pra vocês
conhecerem visitei várias escolas várias
associações institutos de formação de
líderes jovem escolas públicas escolas
particulares enfim foram várias
atividades desenvolvidas que eu me
orgulho bastante e eu quero deixar um
convite pra vocês
vamos juntos nessa missão porque o nosso
propósito é fortalecer a cultura de moda
a dica brasileira levando educação
política a qualquer pessoa e em qualquer
lugar porque a gente tem um sonho grande
eo nosso sonho grande é fortalecer e
tornar o brasil de fato uma democracia
plena e eu tenho uma pergunta pra vocês
o que vocês querem fazer pelo brasil o
que vocês vão fazer pela sociedade
vocês vão ficar só indo votar e
esperando acontecer resultado vocês vão
acompanhar os políticos vão fortalecer a
democracia no seu local no seu município
no seu prédio no seu trabalho
não adianta a gente ficar só esperando
política a gente não vai chegar a lugar
nenhum e eu tenho certeza que daqui a
alguns anos a gente vai poder cantar o
hino do brasil com muito orgulho
uma parte especial que eu gosto muito
que diz o seguinte brasil de amor eterno
seja símbolo e o lábaro que ostentas
estrelado e diga o verde louro desta
flâmula paz no futuro e glória no nosso
passado
muito obrigado e boa noite
[Música]